I first saw this man at Eurovision.
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
And I thought, who is that?
Who is that?
And we all just fell in love with him on the spot.
And if I'm going to rock out with anyone at Christmas,
it's going to be him.
Please welcome Sam Ryder!
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
["RUN RUDOLPH RUN" PLAYING]
[VOCALIZING]
(SINGING) Out of all the reindeer,
you know you're the mastermind.
Run, run, Rudolph.
Randolph's not too far behind.
[CLAPPING]
Run, run, Rudolph.
Santa's got to make it to town.
Randolph, he can hurry.
He can take the freeway down.
And then, away went Rudolph, whizzing like a merry-go-round.
Woo hoo!
Now, let me tell you.
Said Santa to a boy child, what have you been longing for?
Well, all I want for Christmas is a rock and roll
electric guitar.
And then, away went Rudolph, whizzing like a shooting star.
Run, run, Rudolph.
Santa's got to make it to town.
Santa, make him hurry.
Tell him he can take the freeway down.
And then, away went Rudolph, whizzing like a merry-go-round.
Merry Christmas.
Woo hoo!
Yes!
Said Santa to a girl child, what do you like most to get?
I'm ready for you, baby.
I want a baby doll who can cry, drink, scream, oh yeah!
[CHEERING]
And then, away went Rudolph, whizzing like a Saber jet.
Run, run, Rudolph.
Running like a son of a gun.
Then, away went Rudolph, whizzing like a merry-go-round.
Yeah!
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
Ah!
[LAUGHTER]
Oh my gosh.